good evening it's a really great
pleasure to welcome you to our I guess
it's our third evening now this summer
on the hertug Global Studies program we
want to acknowledge our benefactor Roger
hertog who's funded this we have the
seminar running and on Thursday nights
we have distinguished lectures
presentations with the approximately
half hour of audience interaction
afterwards but I see that John topping
truly needs no introduction because he's
already introduced himself to I think
all of you and and this is essential
topping because he really is a people
person and I I was had the pleasure to
meet him in 2006 at the 20th anniversary
of his climate Institute where he had
really a very vast array of different
people of different levels of interests
and expertise and influence and he had
the diplomatic corps of Washington
turned out the president of Iceland and
a lot of evangelical people from
different religious perspectives it was
a marvelous meeting in which you felt
there was some entree for everyone into
the into the conversation and it's
certainly we've heard a lot in past
weeks about climate in a box whether
it's a computerized box of equations or
policy in a box what we feel like we
kind of locked into certain positions
and John really does think outside the
box and and I think his lecture tonight
is going to bring you some of that
perspective he's a graduate of Dartmouth
College he's also a JD from Yale
University and Dartmouth gave him their
first dr. Martin Luther King jr. social
justice award for lifetime achievement
he's very early involved in the in the
civil rights act as an undergraduate and
had a lot of experience networking at a
very local level to bring about the
kinds of bigger results he wanted to see
he's still doing that local connections
on climate issues he's editor of several
volumes on climate change preparing for
climate change coping with climate
change and most recently sudden and
disruptive climate change
he's an optimist and we had a wonderful
about an hour-and-a-half seminar before
this meeting in which he was able to
juxtapose global apocalyptic scenarios
with optimism and and I think I think
he's going to bring us that kind of
perspective now so I think you should
get ready for a very fresh approach
something probably you haven't heard
before and I look forward to your
interaction with John topping let's
welcome him to the hertug Ximena thank
you very much as well I'm delighted to
have the opportunity to be here at
Columbia this Columbia for those of us
in the climate field Columbia and
Boulder Colorado are probably the mecca
and medina of climate change the that
here I i first get active and climate an
82 was introduced john hoffman who is
now unfortunately London with us for the
inspiration for the pilot program green
lights Energy Star Partner in apa
introduced me to Jensen closely from 82
on with jim hansen and of course with
Cynthia Rosenzweig also that gifts which
is both part of NASA but also as a very
close Columbia affiliation and the earth
I worked you know closely with
well a broker lamont-doherty and and
more recently with Jeffrey Sachs at the
Earth Institute and my my daughter
Elizabeth graduated from Dartmouth in
2002 went on and Greta got a master's
degree from sepa in 2006 so there is a
kind of family connection and perhaps
coincidentally or perhaps because of all
the strength here the Communist students
probably hired more people for from
Colombia than any other single school
and so on and now we don't have any
positions I'm not advertising particular
positions right here but I think it's
indicative of you know the strength here
and they've been paid a particularly
we've had a couple people who come from
the climate society program to come to
work for us one person work for us that
then subsidy went to the climate and
society program so I'm delighted to have
the opportunity to speak with you here
and it's coming tonight you know we're
coming after a lot of very significant
developments over the last month or so
you know we all probably saw the various
stories about co2 levels and manalo
hitting 405 than any time in history
human species and you know we've seen a
number of other weather-related stories
or climate related stories including the
Bloomberg administration infection that
New York over the next generation or so
may have a lot more people in the
floodplains so you
many many are going to be much more
vulnerable so tonight I'm going to I'm
going to touch on some of these and I'll
be addressing the Arctic but also
precedent in the Arctic that could could
affect other parts of the globe that are
a very much dear a tipping point the the
Himalayas the the Andes the Amazon
general area in South America tends to
functions and somewhat related ecosystem
and of course again are and how
practical measures to address black
carbon other short-lived climate forcers
could make a big difference than on the
Arctic that the precedent for action
elsewhere and for the lifetime of people
in my generation and even the generation
right after perhaps these volatile
regions are the ones that are going to
be most effective but even for many of
you who may start to see things play out
in other areas much more as well you see
it's important that we see some
victories now and see some these
victories in the area that an area of
the world that would be most affected or
weaker so important now I mentioned the
the co2 measurements at manoa the first
slide shows picture of mount Aloha below
that is the tekele climate Observatory
what's a prime minister who actually
owns and operates of it's the only NGO
operated one in the world in Mexico it's
the highest altitude one and the
measurements there tended Pirlo they're
roughly about two dozen various
greenhouse monitoring places the US and
other countries that all get information
that goes into boulder colorado and that
that's then issued to the world
meteorological organization it's part of
the front of wondering project I think
it's important you know we've seen all
sorts of stories about climate events
but will they do climate change in
climate variability but it's important
to recognize that climate change is not
the only stress that's happening on the
system and often they're additives
dresses are multiplicative not so you
know we're seeing growing the ocean
acidification is maybe a problem it's
perhaps going to be as great as kind of
change we're seeing completion of fossil
aquifers I spoke but in several months
ago in February in the University of
Oklahoma and of course that's an area
that's going to be very affected by the
addition of these microphones here we're
seeing land degradation it interacts
together with climate you know to
increase the risk of family and so on in
order for seeing destruction of forests
especially in tropical regions that is a
real driver and it's being driven a lot
by development pressures now this
particular side right here is probably
the most graphic example of change in
short period of time probably other
other than a few volcanic
eruptions hello so on I don't think
there's probably been any change
indicators and history and human species
quite a significant is this and in
essentially what we've seen in roughly
thirty three years here is a proximate
eighty percent reduction in the volume
of our taxi is not the extent but if you
actually bigger meaning of the total
volume that's interesting we don't know
what all those effects are they they're
probably disruptive and and it's
happened in Larkin short period of time
and at this point this seems of trend
it's likely to continue at the same time
I don't have completely the spirit I
think there is some reason for optimism
that we might get solved the kind of
problem in a way that will avert some of
the most catastrophic potential results
we're seeing China for the surpass the
u.s. is the reading of a house in there
is taking some very strong steps I'm
still building a lot of coal plants and
a lot of things that are very concerned
but they are investing scansion energy
been looking and setting up for the
national carbon tax and cap and trade
system us that historically has produced
about a third of all the greenhouse
mission since the
age is now passed in the second place
and isn't acting excuse me isn't acting
particularly strongly on on climate but
is is acting 21 on the that I mean it's
it's not acting at the national level on
climate but the emissions in nus are
going down substantially they're going
down for a variety of reasons some have
to do a public policy state renewable
portfolio standards some have to do with
corporate action innovation some have to
do it's simply good fortunately the
change in the fossil fuel industry and
drilling practices that allowed
substitution of a lot of only cheap
natural gas for coal for electricity
burning a number of number of things but
the trend appears potentially downward
and that's you know that's positive
despite the fact that in a Washington
looks looks like a dead zone when it
comes to climate change in a lot of ways
these days but also in the u.s. a draft
voluntary standard under the authority
of american national standards institute
ansi that assistance is viking 18 with
markup relegated Ferdie it's coming
forward will be most ambitious among
other things that this emerges as i
expected will sometime next year i'm i'm
one of the 24-member committee and
mature of the of the Subcommittee on
impacts of greenhouse gases and black
carbon but it will for the first time it
will have a
evaluation for reductions of black
carbon and for compounds the resultant
formation covers with goes on that's a
huge defect in occurrences these things
that make the biggest difference f-zero
evaluation in terms of informal trading
systems and it will also create an
artificial warning indicator and that is
something that we were using as a basis
for the formation of a kind of nascent
article I'm in action registry now I
mentioned in addition actions the u.s.
there are other countries of the moving
forward in Mexico that we've been
significant volved in the last hour and
a half the discussion I had classically
described how a country that six seven
years ago wasn't focused much at all in
climate change has now jumped to the
forefront in the OECD way ahead of the
US and canada and it happened because of
the kind of revolution of low a
grassroots revolution inspired partly by
my colleagues who created a sense of
national pride in the attic LOL
observatory and then built over the next
several years 14 climate theaters and
equivalents of planetariums for climate
education that spurred such a change
that in mexico he had a last year a
remarkable development and after the
house of representatives passed
something much stronger than
waxman-markey that made it barely
through the house and didn't make the
florida US Senate in a few years ago
that Mexico
passed by ninety percent margin in the
house and by a hundred percent margin
every every senator including the right
of center pan people voting for
something stronger than you know
something could even get before in the
u.s. it was signed into law by then
right and center president felipe
calderon and the current president
Enrique Pena Nieto for whom we built for
climate theaters when he was the
governor of the state of Mexico you know
it seems he seems determined to you know
go seriously with implementation of this
now the focus of my lecture tonight is
really going to be on a couple things
one the urgency from a general
standpoint of acting on Climate to on
short life climate forcers a short life
when fortunes would be recent black
carbon particles compounds result in
trouble sir it goes on
complex photochemistry the various
locally and so forth and an also method
and if we can act on those globally we
can move the full process but I'm also
arguing tonight that we need to double
down on those particularly these Stowey
regions three poles in the North or
South Pole in the Himalayas of those
regions and and also in the Andes the
most rapid loss of glaciers in these
regions essentially pose or a real
problem for us the two component of
regions or accelerating cielo rise and
the others in terms of loss of water
supplies and hydroelectric power as well
but the I'm also going to touch upon the
a car and the Arctic climate actually
registered which is kind of nascent
everything but in the structure for
we're hoping very sitting to have the
final life cycle standard that we can
use as the basis for this and of course
we need to attract some you know some
action funding resources to put this
boolean invitation but we have we have
24 virtual Arctic virtual fellows and
interns are working with us to set up
you know do various research projects
and all others in preparation for this
and personally welcome any of you here
to participate in this effort but I'm
hoping you know the if we succeed in a
car that we will establish a precedent
for regionally focused strategies that
can be used in some of these other
regions you know the I mentioned
the I've mentioning and the Antarctic
the Amazon in the Himalayas the
Antarctic is warming parts of the
Antarctic the are warming quite rapidly
and the effect is that we are seeing
some negotiation in the interdependency
Westerner a sheet etc and this can add
to the molding for green roughly the
bremen and the Antarctica producing
roughly about the same amount of
additional contribution of relaxing so
this is a real concern the Amazon is a
concern out of itself of biodiversity as
a result of land conversion there's a
danger by back but also it looks as
though the burning than the Amazon and
within some of the surrounding
aggressive areas around could affect the
Andes and the the inter-american
Development Bank the team led live all
over there
issue 5 or 6 weeks of our newsletter
that will then we'll focus on on these
regions and we hope that mark on this
and will show something and they
himalayan in tibetan plateau we're
talking about water for the large
portion of the planet that can only be
been affected here the interestingly
there has some activity under way in
this us under then Secretary of State
Hillary Rodham Clinton and its
continuing us is still continuing the
activeness really launched a climate and
clean air coalition it's focused largely
on these short lifetime enforcers and
also in hydro fluorocarbons we recently
saw an agreement in the in the u.s.
Chinese summit on on hfcs and you know I
think that you know that was promising
and indicates the potential for some
sort of action among the two major
superpowers but what's significant here
is that these these reductions you'll
not only human health effects but they
they yield and other other effects
methane reductions for example could
reduce coal mine guests from accidents
methane also can be used for from fuel
generation and so on their writing of
variety of benefits and of course
reducing produce Erica's own also helps
crops as well as help people's health
and sewing but a major barrier we have
at this point is the the current the
Kyoto system does not incentivize
reductions of these short life climate
forcers that's something that the ANSI
standard is now being developed will
help to address I'm not going to run
over quickly here
the these short light climate forces
trump sir goes on popularly often the
ground level called smog major effects
we don't like it here's our eyes up it
has you know more severe effects than
that it can have major effects of crops
it's up generally for less than a month
but it does produce a substantial
warming effect by some kind of relations
about it's about eighteen percent of
what we associate with co2 methane or
methane on the other side of the pond is
a very significant greenhouse gas it
lasts roughly a decade or so atmosphere
and it's warming effect is a little bit
over fifty percent of that of co2 but
because it it's up for only about a
decade or so if you can if you can make
major changes in nothing you can reduce
the concentrations and this was going to
have an impact also there are so many
win-win effects from harvesting you know
whether harvesting this from landfills
other things that you know there are
there benefits with actions in Syria
black carbon is something that has
really gotten attention recently Jim
Hanson when he was director of goddard
intraface studies created a lot of the
first u.s. focus and this doctor dr.
Robin Nathan at UC San Diego and
Carmichael of both done seen in a major
subsequent work can't candy bond at the
University of Illinois also on this but
it there are some indications that the
effects may be as much as fifty five
percent in the effects of MCA to the
effects some regions such as the artic
where the
the effect of the soot particles in
effect on the on the snow and ice
magnifies the the Melbourne and so on
and this adds to the other other warming
effects that the associated with this
but what's also interesting here is that
black carbon or the various compounds of
particular compounds that are our black
carbon also aren't good to breathe and
they and other related particular
produce roughly three million deaths
annually worldwide so the action on this
can make a big difference now this this
slide shows a little bit of regional
facts to people right in the Columbia
community you know coated very much
showing these effects on the Arctic
quite substantial you know both Jim
Hansen and Andrew chandelle and and I
commend you know what look to some of
their studies on this the major benefits
of black carbon reduction are really
that we can make a big difference
quickly and
you know slow the warming we can
decrease the art the warming in the
Arctic and conceivably in some of these
other regions that I mentioned earlier
and to the extent that we produce
introductions we're going to save a lot
of lives this these slides were prepared
by based on work by our the climate is
to chief scientist Mike McCracken who
really did a lot to alert people to the
policy potential of acting on black
carbon and the major paper did in june
two thousand eight the what's
significant this is firming effect
during the 21st century if we have a
recip reductions in both greenhouse
gases and black carbon what it shows is
you can take the black carbon out much
more quickly and there's a you know the
first part of the slide is the 20 the
20th century co2 emissions that are
going to be with us for a long while
then there the next one is this 21st
century co2 emissions then then methane
from Serco's on other greenhouse gases
and then finally at the top and black or
the black carbon potential this is what
happens with business as usual this is
looking taking this out over this
between now and 20 40 and if we go with
aggressive reductions and we've got a
chance of really avoiding going past
many of the worst of the tipping points
and black carbon can think you can play
a very big role in this now what's
significant here we are now moving into
the artic the biggest single for sir in
the Arctic at this point or is it
biomass burning
have been slight as numbers they
projected from NASA's our tests mission
but it's it's also true that within the
biomass burning which is driving much of
agricultural and grassland fires are the
biggest single factor I mean forest
fires you know plays a a significant
role but the hard way the largest role
is delivered burning and and it's
associate and it happens to be in
certain parts of the world particularly
you know the largest number these
emissions come from Russia second
largest from Kazakhstan China US Canada
the Ukrainian roughly in that order
based on study that was done published
in 2009 the and most of these countries
have some form or another of limitation
on agricultural burning but as a
practical matter it's often relaxed
enforced the you know mitigation
strategies here would involve
enforcement of existing rules changing
seasonality of burning the in Australia
they've done various changes in
seasonality the agricultural burning
which can make a significant difference
now that would be more for the Antarctic
and everything else these were you know
undertaken for other reasons and climate
primarily but it is it is doable and
it's possible that you know that can can
help significantly now another thing
that we weren't very aware of until
quite recently that appears to be
driving things driving warming a lot of
the Arctic is arctic air plane over
flights I myself traveled to Beijing a
couple times were back and forth this
year at least two flights for two of
those 40,000 points for ones that I was
involved in and this didn't happen much
before 98 the Russians at that point
gave an okay to do commercial
million flights of Russia and at that
point we suddenly started seeing this
happening there are some indications
that in Chanel America's with us here
tonight is very humorous dr. Jacobson at
Stanford University is done calculations
of the slice and and what's significant
here is that the these black carbon
emissions in the stratosphere often
lasts about ten times longer than they
do at ground level so the the effect is
they may stay up depending in time of
year as much as 70 some days so the
effect of one ton of black carbon
released in the stratosphere may be the
equivalent of several hundred thousand
tons of co2 so the effects are I can be
enormous and you know when released of
the art and that's something that
Jacobson has an interesting paper I
commend to you it's it's open source you
can just go you know just Google for
work
take him some rerouting of Arctic
flights came out in 2012 that
essentially suggests the cost for
rerouting most of the trans Arctic
flights would be about 99 million
dollars a year I mean it's something
that could be very doable and according
his calculations can make a huge
difference in turn she was around summer
sea ice there was a new story out here
early that early this month that the
members of the International Air
Transport Association basically
represents about 80 some percent of the
commercial air traffic in the world has
urged governments to drop some some of a
single market-based system so you know
they haven't yet bought into action in
the Arctic at least there's some
movement in the airline industry and our
hope is that you know some practical
actions could be taken that would not
put firms of too much of a competitive
disadvantage because this could make a
huge difference jacobsen i believe the
tributes perhaps as much as twenty
percent of the one near overflights and
some others to take more more cautious
approach but it still appears that it's
something significantly if changed to
make a big difference now one of the
things I wanted to talk to you about is
development related to the Arctic on
other areas shipping that right now is
not a big factor in artic emissions but
it could become a significant factor if
we we see a lot more open waters in the
Arctic due to the melting of the ice and
to the extent that the ships generate a
lot of black carbon you know that's
going to accelerate the laws to the
extent that the ships of electrostatic
precipitators or change fuel mixes or
change
engine design and so on he had to
greatly reduce those adverse impacts
well and gas development well I'm not
eager to see a whole lot of that but
there's obvious at rush rush on in the
Arctic and a minimum it seems that one
of the things we should be seeking to do
is insist that any firms that are
developing oil and gas activity you know
within the northern regions article your
article eegees should go for a minimum
suit emission standard and and almost no
methane release you know that could make
a very big difference and what
significant is at the ground level on an
annual basis which is probably in a
perfect day since the RT the 11 ton of
black carbon is roughly equivalent of
about forty four thousand tons of co2 so
the effect of these these auxiliary
vehicles that the trucks and other
things of if they're pretty dirty and
admitting this may be much more
consequential than the incremental co2
even it will
generated from the energy that comes out
of that so that's something that's
important it's also important recognize
that for place like Russia probably our
US NGOs aren't going to have a major
impact on on Russian development
environment policy but on the other hand
to extent it the major majors they're
partnering in Russia in any activity US
Canada commit themselves to essentially
zero black carbon zero methane release
it's going to be hard for them not to do
the same thing in Russia and that could
affect companies like most after etc so
it's kind of indirect way of affecting
things in Russia than the other guys
probably don't have a lot of say over in
significant and mining mining activities
right now nickel mines in the US and and
excuse me a nickel mines in Canada and
in Russia may be significant sources of
our carbon Greenland right now is
finding most of the most of the
emissions in Greenland are coming from
the US and Canada basically diesel
diesel fuel some agricultural brownie
etc there are not too much comes from
greening but number if you've probably
seen stories about developing pressures
and Greenland the Chinese are
considering building a an iron mine in
Greenland bringing in 2100 Chinese
workers the various folks in Europe
North America and Asia are also looking
at rare earth development to the extent
that any of this development happens in
Greenland it's imperative that the there
be essentially zero black carbon
standards and and hope I hope the new
Greenlandic government was elected in
March would be very receptive to this
and there seems some concern about
making sure that the min
development happens in a constructive
way that doesn't disrupt the local
ecosystems too much now I want to touch
briefly on a kind of an area that is
essentially a kind of last resort in the
Arctic Jim Fleming Israel expert in this
whole area of manias done books and
weather modification and knows how
fraught with peril a lot of the
approaches would be and also the
politics of very difficult in any case
for this I highlighted here three
possibilities that are probably among
the more more of the mind the
possibilities of you know what you might
call kind of geoengineering one that's
advanced by a couple of experts and a
group in UK called their Arctic methane
emergency group essentially we be the
ship send some small ships out to spray
salt and do some generate clouds that we
essentially enhance albedo and so on
their micro Kraken our chief scientist
has talked to some folks who have been
concerned about who have suggested the
possibility of changing the seasonality
of ice breaking so if you did the ice
breaking more in the fall unless in the
spring you know that could end up having
a beneficial effect no I not enough of
an expert on I ice-breaking to to know
well this appears to be scientifically
valid how how easy it would be to do in
the real world of shipping and so forth
but that that's a possibility there's
another exotic possibility of
essentially gobbling up nothing
with Anna trucks and so on and you know
some some interesting articles exist on
this this would have a potential if it
works perhaps of generating fish from
fish farms and so on offshore areas and
so on you know these are areas that need
a lot of research at this point and if
if we strike out on on the admissions
mitigation strategies we may need to
have some sort of backup but i just
mentioned them but i think it's jim
knows it's crucially important before we
do this that we developed it can the
consent of the people who are going to
be affected that's the the eight arctic
council member countries the various
indigenous organizations you also
represent on the Arctic Council and and
we feel tested this beforehand so we
know there aren't a lot of unintended
side effects now I'm going to talk
tonight a little bit about four crucial
regions the Himalayas often called the
third Pole the Amazon II and rainforests
the Andean mountains in some of the
surrounding an Amazonian basin area the
Antarctica and Christy cardigan now
what's interesting in South America
there are these ecosystems that are you
know closely connected that they need of
the player play a role each and the
other the Amazonian rainforest plays a
crucial role for the whole globe in
terms of biodiversity it plays a huge
role for Latin America in terms of
Federation of enough water to support a
lot of agricultural systems and we're
seeing large losses here due to land
conversion from trading cattle farms for
mining
operations etc and that that itself
creates a danger of died back of a
forest that could could become
self-fulfilling we have some Brazilian
scientists see marsh and evangelista who
three years ago issued a report showing
emissions from burning in the Amazon
we're showing up very much in the
Antarctic about fifty percent of the
black carbon showing up the Antarctic
that's coming from there and I think
about thirty percent from from Africa
and most of the remainder was coming
from from Australia and in the Andes you
know the most rapid glacier loss is the
Indian mountains the this imperils water
supplies and efforts are underway in
some andean communities to install
various cook stoves there was a major
meeting of the International cook stove
Alliance recently in brew and a a year
and a half hence Peru is going to be the
host of the next appears likely to be
the host of the next major climate
conference the as far as Antarctica is
concerned you know we've all seen
various projections that we can see as
much as 200 feet of sea level rise if
all the Antarctic Ice Sheet burn can
melt but you know we don't need to see
nearly that kind of melting to see some
rather dramatic effects on the world of
large what these slides give it a little
bit of an indication of some of the
change and so on here and there there
there to be posted there posted both in
climate authority
the Columbia site as well want to go at
this in a little more detail and what
significant here is there is some rapid
warming happening in parts of the
Antarctic the Antarctic is a net
contributor to seal her eyes at this
point the roughly about as much as green
and and right now the annual
congregations are comfortably modest but
it seems to be kicking up perhaps in
both places and if that happens this
could you know this could add greatly to
see horizon and rather than having the
roughly 1 meter or so when perhaps as
much of 2 meters silver eyes we can see
something even greater than that at this
point the you know there's black carbon
there we we don't know how much of a
role is playing in in the worry in the
butt but it's plausible with its having
some effect probably not as much as the
Arctic or neah Malaya's still some
consequence now the Himalayas are
significant they're the source of water
for a large portion of the world
we affect the climate system of monsoon
system etc the
what what is significant is we were
seeing we're seeing some indications of
real change in the Himalayas that in the
generation or two could seriously
threaten water supplies and the Andean
effects are here now the effects of the
Himalayas are you know likely about the
middle of the century we see Stephen C
second place Isaac initially the melting
of the glaciers probably produces some
increase of water but after after period
of time you know the effects would be it
could be in a quite damaging project
Syria that dr. ramanathan at UCSD has
been spearheading is seeking to reduce
black carbon both for climate reasons
also for reasons in human health trying
to arrange financing for replacement
cook stoves kerosene lanterns etc also
the the indian supreme court acted
recently in a something driven not by
climate considerations but by
considerations in human health to
mandate compressed natural gas replace a
lot of the particular generating decent
it was operating in urban areas and
there now i'm going to touch on the the
Arctic in the Arctic climate action
registry right here here this is an
indication The Economist has a slide
showing dramatic changes that have
happened in the summer sea ice in recent
years just from over the last several
decades you've seen a Vatican mission in
this you know the most dramatic of
course was the volume is the icing on
the early sites of showed the that here
we're seeing we're seeing a process that
is quite alarming and ish alee the
thought was that we could have a nice
free Arctic at the end of the summer by
sometime the latter part of the century
now it's a real possibility you could
see this happening by the end of this
decade and whoops but here we are him
sorry and the as far as climate change
in the Arctic is concerned you know one
of the concerns by touched on before was
the melting of the Greenland ice sheet
these slides were taken you know there
was a time in roughly four days and in
july of last year were roughly ninety
seven percent of green and showed some
degree of melting it was quite dramatic
and it really shocked a lot of
scientists they couldn't believe what
they're seeing now it's not ninety seven
percent of the ice sheet melt but
ninety-seven percent was showing you
know some portion of knowing and this
indicates they possibility we could see
some some acceleration the you know the
melting of the ice sheet of course would
add to sea level rise
and other changes are major incursion
you're threatening villages collapse of
entire ecosystem changes of way of life
for for indigenous peoples and of course
the the real shocker and is the
potential of melding of the permafrost
and methane and methane also in some of
the ocean sediments settlements chief
causes here are general global warming
you know co2 and other caused by other
gases but but our artificial
contribution that information could be
as much as it and it's coming from the
short life code enforcers and there's a
and there's this outlier possibility
maybe maybe unfortunately not an outlier
of the methane hydrate pulse that could
make a very big difference now what are
there are a number of climate impacts
our early showing up in the first
environment rough geez in the world
maybe in the United States for his
villages in Alaska on substantial basis
the we're seeing loss of public
infrastructure that's happening in
Alaska is happening Russia permafrost
melt gia forcing the location of
pipelines changing the highways etc food
security as being affected their effects
on human health now when the last guy
mentioned we have the first environment
of geez the GAO has done some studies
essentially showing a number of villages
facing imminent threats and and the
number of these are also exploring
relocation possibilities now this there
are about four million people in the in
the Arctic region this shows the
indigenous people about 400,000 are
using these people but they're taking
the brunt of the better they're they're
the ones who plays the ways of life are
being affected and
and of course in the case of Greenland
excuse me in the case of of Alaska in
the US where they're likely to be
displaced now what is the significance
for international security well I think
there are a couple things in terms of
the changes they re 1 to the extent that
the we see melting in the Arctic we see
melting in the NRA that's got you have
is going to see increase the pressures
on places like the origin London Tokyo
departed and so forth also a possibility
exists probably a very likely that
Boston around summer tis will change
whether in ocean circulation patterns in
a substantial way probably not
particularly good now the Arctic climate
action registry is an effort to
incentivize your reductions of Sid and
other emissions and it it is created a
it's seeking to put together a social
network of scientists business leaders
and others and we hope if successful it
could be extended to some of these other
grove regions is its vision and set
forth right here essentially it wants to
make a difference by incentivizing these
reductions and in its daily projects
the there are a number of groups of
vulture the vestments including the
climate of student and security
committee were acting is the umbrella
for this we have transactional registry
American Krav Maga Jesus existed since
that's it for the past 17 years has a
long history of doing various voluntary
deduction credit crediting systems in
Italy to essentially act as the banking
in a system and so forth of them and
then be a third-party validator SCS
global services in California which is
going on third-party verifier and we
have a hope to have a group of folks
functioning his artic climate protection
network the number of leading experts in
the Arctic NGOs the head of probe
launched international the southern
Alliance for clean energy and others are
involved in this there's some
international involvement we're hoping
to have some come Russian well this
gives you some indication of membership
the and the her the current
you know chair of the steering committee
Charlie Bayless is a former utility
executive instead of Tucson Electric in
Illinois power and president West
Virginians to the technology and a
passionate believer in action yarded the
hear this discusses some possibilities
in Chipping air travel Lucian generation
coming from nickel smelters and other
possibilities methane captured and of
course if we go so far as to do
engineering perhaps natural cycle in
hillsboro now there are some mildly
encouraging trends despite what I've
suggested here one u.s. Commission
levels have started to drop almost in
1994 levels it's happening for a variety
of reasons that are partly a function of
conscious public policy partly a
function of good fortune changed
drilling techniques that are allowing
natural gas to replace coal and electric
abilities but it's crucial that we do
have this movement to from coal to gas
that we we go to absolute minimum
methane leakage from the system we can
hold it down to like a one-percent total
from the whole natural gas system you
know then the movement is is a clear
plus now it's important you know that
you know that I think we take advantage
of this situation for the u.s. to become
leader on on black on addressing short
life climate forcers and and so on and
we also have other opportunities reduce
using energy recycling as is true in
Greenland promoting action on
short-lived climate forcers and also
recognizing we have to recognize the
politics of this issue are are more
promising with a lot of array of
senators you would never expect to have
together
willing to address this because we all
breathe this air in so forth now finally
I'm going to touch on China the Chinese
are are starting to move aggressively on
this I mean they leave surpassed assists
leading committers but they're looking
at putting together a cap-and-trade
system they're looking at setting up a
tax on carbon there now investing
roughly about 65 billion in energy us in
2012 it was 35 billion and they're
producing about half of the solar panels
that will be us it's quite a bit less
than that although when we want some
leaders in the area and what's also
significant is China in the last few
weeks has given some indications
privately that they're looking at
cranking black carbon into their
greenhouse system now finally the ACARS
target just dissing system because
summary is ystem is to create the basis
for a region-specific mitigation
strategy they can double down production
of these short life forces and if if
this succeeds in
in coming together you know we hope it
becomes the basis for action so much
more broadly well thank you thank you
very much and I'm delighted with any
questions John my question is whether
stopping climate change is the right
goal so does the does the climate
Institute aim to stop climate change
well we will never completely stop
climate change you know I think it's
going to happen to you know to some
extent but what we what we need to do is
to slow climate change enough that it's
within the capacity of humanity and
ecosystems to adapt I mean there are
some levels of climate change that are
inconsistent with continuation of many
species and planet including our other
our own there are other levels you know
that that are much less severe so I I
think what you're talking about it's a
combination of mitigation and an
adaptation strategy you know together
you know but we know you know climate
system itself will go through a certain
amount of change in any case they're
just you know because of natural climate
variability but what what we're fighting
right here is this shocking effect in
the near term of changes that are
happening as indicated with the the
volume of sea ice in
incredibly short period of time a third
of a century and if that sort of thing
happens you're you're you're talking
about grave dangers not only for the
human species but for you know many
others in this planet the cockroaches
may survive all of us but but so I mean
just so I understand so the climate
Institute website and also Mike
McCracken and some of his published work
he does talk about how we should stop
climate change but doesn't that give
people the wrong idea about about
climate change I mean has there ever
been a time in which climate change I
mean that any ever been a time in which
climate has stopped changing well III
think what we're talking about is
stopping the severely disruptive effects
of that I mean essentially buying us
enough time you know the Indiana in the
human ingenuity can essentially respond
to this if it happens too fast no matter
how smart we rated you know be it's got
to be very hard to get you know get past
that so so that's that's essentially
what we're talking about I I think you
know it Mike would certainly recognize
this that the changes is sizable
that you know that that were quite
sizable that were experienced and that
we're facing and if we can cut that in
half or and cut that down substantially
that it buys time for future generations
that otherwise are going to be placed in
a very grave pearl okay thank you you
mentioned the fact that the
stratospheric overflights of Russia
produces ten times the amount of carbon
has produced a sealable I guess is the
idea that the carbon produced by that
flight will be offset by by the trade
I'm not I don't quite understand it is
there any plan to actually reduce the
amount of carbon that's submitted by
these overflight planes or is it what
what what there is an interesting
article you know google for marc
jacobson article rear out and you can
find it it's it's actually it's
fortunately it's one of these open
source of publications that stanford and
what he did was model rerouting of the
flight so the fights that didn't
originate in the Arctic but that you
know that originated elsewhere were
routed to be a little bit of an
additional fuel costs fuel costs would
be a fraction of one percent but he
translated this to for all the flights
something like 99 million dollars a year
and the and because you know the of the
long persistence time of the black
carbon that's released into the
stratosphere it plays a much more
substantial role than you would think
and that's that's essentially the basis
of it so the idea is that these flights
would go around the Arctic a little bit
more now you know how you actually make
that happen in the real world of
competitive airline traffic is you know
is a real challenge for us but the I
mean lots people recognize this is one
of the biggest things that's driving
it's possible that we could get some
action and then maybe the airlines
that formally we're getting people
around the planet might might have taken
an extra hour or so for the flight you
know could it could adjust but it's
there there would be there would be a
slight additional co2 penalty but to be
given that the black carbon effects on
the climate or maybe 400 or 500 thousand
times as great as the ton of co2 effect
that the additional additional co2 that
we generated we'd be quite minor as
compared to the other but he does in his
article he does look at the trade-off
between the carbon dioxide effects and
the black carbon effects for points or
point sources of electricity production
such as coal-burning power plants or
natural gas burning power plants there
are a huge contributor of a lot of
emissions and and black particulates how
would that be reduced to zero in the
near future well it it wouldn't be
reduced in so 20 but let's say for
example you're dealing with a an energy
project the Arctic at least if they put
diesel filters on the diesel trucks that
are used in that that would be one you
may make a big difference the state of
Alaska is where there are a lot of
Native villages are going to be facing
displacement has is looking at replacing
some of the expensive diesel generation
capacity that is also polluting
and happens to be very expensive with
tidal energy you know and so there are a
variety of different possibilities I
mean they're you know they're they vary
a lot from place to place but in that
case you would you find a dramatic
reduction and in the in the case of the
of the diesel trucks and are the the
trucks and the other off-road vehicles
we know there are there are traps that
can reduce by ninety percent or more the
generation that can happen from these
vehicles so it's a combination of these
things won't quite be zero carbon but
but it might be ninety-seven percent
reductions in some cases and that can
make a huge difference when these
effects or as large as they are
I'm wondering whether fracking causes
climate change in any way well it really
depends on on whether there's a lot of
methane release and I mean the I mean
it's a it's a very much a double-edged
sword into I mean fracking you know
they're obviously concerns about
fracking in terms of water supplies and
other things in any case but the there's
a lot of work that's being done and some
of the you know some of the leading
abramo groups in verbal Defense Fund and
worldwatch institute and others have
been looking a lot at some of these
issues and the what you what you face is
if if you can hold the natural gas
leakage including from the fracking
process minimally there are advantages
in the near term for substituting
natural gas for coal and but on the
other hand if you get up to something
like the three or four percent leakage
right it starts to shift the other way
and there's no particular advantage in
its cold of course there are some of the
aroma groups and said look you know the
situation is so bad at this point that
we really need to go completely tuned on
carbon fuels and you know relying too
heavily on uh natural gas as a
transition itself as a problem I mean
you know there are you know I think
they're all very very legitimate
viewpoints at this point but but at this
at this time a lot of work is now going
on EDF is right here in town they're
they're looking very closely at at some
of these these issues
I I hope that will you know we'll have
you know better a better answer on that
question but at this point it's a
question mark I'll take it prerogative
to ask a question to or following up on
on professor Connolly's comment about
stopping climate change week we had last
week some conversation about climate in
a way psychology grief counseling people
feeling that they've lost their
connection with nature and they can do
nothing except sort of more in the loss
of this and the same was part of I think
Bill McKibben's early book on the death
of nature you talked earlier and not in
this lecture we talked about
intergenerational hope and ways to bring
creative action back into the game and
and I wanted to two highlights what you
talked about action on whether can
actually be action on climate if you
save people from severe storms if you
save lives or improve livability you
know through some smart actions you're
talking about the football helmets
during tornadoes to reduce brain
injuries if you take action on pollution
and health as you're talking about black
carbon you're actually improving lung
health but you're using it as a proxy
for climate improvement and so this is
what I meant when I say that John and
his group thinks outside the box but i
think that metaphor itself could have
some limitations where if you get
outside the box on on standard climate
honk stand and and sort of frozen policy
options you're also in a way as far as I
was listening to the geoengineering side
possibly getting outside of other boxes
as well as as maybe it's Pandora's box
that you're getting outside of when I
think of the Arctic methane emergency
group it's not gotten really good
reviews it's sort of a ad hoc hodgepodge
of people retired engineers people with
perhaps proprietary interest in their
techniques and maybe pushing the
emergency
for other than than admirable completely
admirable reasons or or maybe I wouldn't
even go that far just saying they're
getting beyond their scientific basis of
expertise and we don't have a good model
of that occur together outgassing an
emergency so I a question it's a very
long introduction to this but in some
ways you're advocating actions that are
outside of a stasis on climate policy
climate science but in other cases you
might be a little out there a little
further beyond at least bringing up the
am EG and bringing up some of the the
other ideas especially that we could do
field tests on mon geoengineering prior
to scaling them up to full size this is
this is right at the cutting edge of
geoengineering concern right now so
wouldn't monitoring and and and and and
and the kind of win-win practical policy
things be it be a bit more more
supportable than the out there kind of
outside the box so i just want you to
ruminate a bit about how how far outside
the box can we get on creative climate
solutions well Jim I you know for the
other the whole focus of the Arctic
climate action registry is on emission
reductions right and I think on the
other hand I would encourage you know
the scientific community to start
looking at other things but one of the
things we know is that the Arctic is an
iconic location and it's like the
Galapagos and the folks who get involved
in iron fertilization made a huge
mistake when they decided they were
going to some spring a big project in
the glove case and company doing it
essentially went out of business and so
forth you know there are these things
that have to be tested and lab they have
to be tested in places that are
relatively safe and then before you do
something of the sort
to be safely tested and you have to know
that they're not going to be a lot of
side effects you have to develop consent
among those and Jim you are probably the
world expert on exactly this you know
how sensitive you know this is so I
think it's important that you know some
research go on in this but as a
practical matter the even with you know
changes in in the cloud effects well it
sounds rattling the nine it could change
whether circulation patterns and of
course then maybe three-quarters the
people benefit one quarter don't and
that's still a problem even if you could
could see major gains so I think that
our focus right now is is it's largely
on emission reductions one of the one of
the things that I did cite in there that
I think it's probably a safer one would
be changing the seasonality of the ice
break I don't I don't think there's you
know how how practical would will be
debited or oh well it's another question
but I don't think there's much when
adverse effect and if they individual
individual country blind encourage that
I don't think other could have grounds
to to object to it
hi I've got a question about 350 and
Bill McKibben I'm so you talked you know
before this larger talk we were talking
about young people and kind of solutions
and now and we've been talking about
kind of causes for optimism I'm
wondering how you see 350 in that
context you know it seems like they've
had a lot of success compared to other
environmental groups by taking an
extremely intransigence stance toward
new fossil fuel developments as winning
if you think that this is also part of
the solution and that their things we
could learn from them or if you think
that this kind of intransigence is to to
black and white and distracting us from
other kinds of solutions you know I
think that you know they they played a
significant role in the issue one of the
things that I was encouraged to read an
article that was this morning the bill
is going to Greenland with some others
they're looking a lot of black Hartman
fix would be nice if and looking at some
of these effects in northern areas it
would start looking not not just at the
additional co2 at the other if they do
that I think you know that will build in
a much more of a kind of basis of
understanding for this so I you know I
think they play a constructive role at
the same time you we are going to have
to affect some of these oil and gas
projects that whatever bill and I may
think about them are probably going to
happen and to the extent you're going to
affect Russia you know
it's going to be imperative make sure
that Exxon and Chevron and others in
their activities do it do their
activities in the US and canada with
minimum collateral damage in terms of
black carbon and methane release and to
the extent they do that that they lock
themselves in and lock in their partners
you know such as Rose Nev and so forth
into activities there so I think that I
mean you know we all have to work on
this because if the Arctic really goes
to hell in the basket it's it's going to
affect us all profoundly and you know
the the Arctic climate action registry
is one means of doing this and I think
some of the activist groups or another
and perhaps at some point this gets way
out of hand and we've tested some of
these climate engineering projects they
even end up playing a role but i think
you know at the moment we know we have
to do everything we can to go after the
short-lived climate forcers and put the
primary focus on that thank you very
much for being here with us and a
question with regards to you'd mentioned
in our workshop before kind of how the
Kyoto Protocol was short lived in terms
of its inability to address things like
black carbon for instance do you think
there's a hope in addressing these
short-term climate forcers through
another similar form of
intergovernmental agreement to a summer
scale III think there is there some hope
we're working on the I mean the very
fact of the that the Chinese are going
with the trading system and I've
privately heard that the Chinese are
looking at cranking black carbon into
the system if the world's leading
emitter in both producer of carbon
dioxide anna by carving moves that way
the u.s. through a voluntary standard
you could have most robust standard the
world that creates evaluation eventually
the climate trading system will catch up
with it I mean the Quetta system is
lagging a generation in this regard
behind the science and so forth if this
happens then you know I think we'll
start seeing that kind of a change now
what was significant in the in the
recent US China summit there was a major
agreement on the part of the US and
China to act on hydro fluorocarbons that
are you know in the longer term likely
to be a significant contributor and the
there were some calculations that if if
these actions were followed through you
know by substitutes and you know the
whole thing that fully implemented you
could be talking over the next over the
century of as much as half a degree
Celsius reduction in the warming that
otherwise might be anticipated so there
are a lot of these you know these things
I think where there's hope but part of
it is probably getting us and Chinese
leadership and then part of it is
developing some sort of voluntary
standards that eventually become an ISO
and recognize that for a lot of
multinational companies who want to be
regarded as forward-looking and so forth
these voluntary standards are something
I really aspire to so it can actually
affect multi-billion dollar investments
and watch a company you know whether
it's an energy company or whether it's a
a retail company starts to fly in on
this and strips it through sends it
through its supply chain that can have
profound effects and so I'm I see this
happening in a lot of different ways
there's an interesting book i'm arguing
by Brown and Silva cool that talks about
Polly centrism that you know these
effects have to happen at a whole
variety of different levels and then
some of them are in the corporate
sectors some of them are at the state
and local governments some that are
happening internationally and I think we
get into the idea and you know many of
my mic confers and the climate movement
most of whom were lawyers as I am you
know what get this as a way of
essentially carving up the world and
getting a binding agreement of doing
that and the world is much more subtle
than that and you know much more nuanced
and I think I think if we're going to
succeed in climate change it's going to
happen by tapping into folks I've been
spending a lot of the last you know
three years commuting back 14 Washington
hannover trying to develop working with
something we call center for our
leadership training it's a virtual
center of a couple dozen students at
Dartmouth and about 30 students
skeletor's fair to else around the
planet we're gathering smart solutions
you know blogs on climate change we
developed we gather the other slides in
Chinese Arabic Spanish French Portuguese
English and we're developing game on the
artery and I welcome anybody here to
sort of join with us in this effort and
the idea is to uuuuu tap people together
together with working with these
voluntary standards and if we have this
action happening from variety directions
the public policy process will gradually
move along and maybe we'll do ten
percent of it but about ninety percent
is going to happen outside
international negotiations thank you q
hi I guess my question is a bit of a
follow-up from our files question I'm
curious what your personal opinion is as
to the future of global governance as
far as climate change security
implications are concerned I know
there's been a lot of talk of extending
UNHCR definition of refugee to include a
climate change refugee and there doesn't
really seem to be much agreement on that
so i guess i'm just wondering what's
your take on the future of of a
potential agreement that deals
particularly the security implications
of climate change well I I think in some
areas it's it's probably very doable but
it may not be a hundred eighty countries
necessarily agree I mean if you get on
some of these areas if you get the US
and China to agree or US and China and
India or or whatever you know that may
make a big difference also when you
start yelling adaptation into their
Island State situations that are
comfortable or island state and
developing island states in Bangladesh
Indonesia and Vietnam and and and and so
forth could have a lot of actions
together and I I I think it's and I have
enormous respect for christianity giris
who's the who heads the the overall
international process but whoever is
there it's really going to be face faced
with the situation that the world you
know it often more and more is going to
be making major decisions through other
than formal international processes it's
going to be a lot of you know voluntary
processes it's going to be getting ideas
out and so forth and it's creating this
global community if we have to depend on
a couple hundred thousand of us who
travel back and forth to climate
meetings and energy meetings and
bloviate and and so forth and probably
generate more and and pressures on the
on the climate in our air flights that
we necessarily
do good forget it for the major cities
of the world but on the other hand if if
we can have 50 million or a hundred
million people not just playing angry
birds I can still play Angry Birds and
World of Warcraft and so on but spend a
little bit of time maybe an hour to a
week on on climate solutions solutions
for water resources smarter ways of
doing things if we do that and but the
good thing about this is is your
generation are your folks who created
the major social media companies you
grew up from age six or seven or so
playing games and so forth you have this
kind of savvy you also have a passionate
environmental commitment so if you could
if we confuse this together you know and
then we tie that together with some
actions on climate change some policy
actions to sort of be necessary but the
politics start to change and in and in
Mexico as I mentioned earlier we had the
the Senate in april of last year by
unanimous vote even though all the right
of center pan members voting for it
passed something much stronger than
waxman-markey that never made it to the
Senate floor in the US and it's now law
mexico has the most aggressive climate
law of any osed nation and so on and i
think some action has to happen there
but it happened because it came from the
people it came from below and so on it
didn't come from above and people didn't
feel that there was being forced upon
them and that's crucially important
okay well John we're delighted that you
are here with us tonight and thank you
for this vision of of a new generation
making a difference and different
coalition's coming together around your
kind of ability to bring us together
thank you thank you we're I'm also happy
to invite you back here next thursday at
six o'clock the series continues with
Anthony Jeanette oz who is an expert on
climate change and well maybe John would
you like to talk about tell me tell you
honey and I claim the credit for the it
wasn't it wasn't Star Wars it was Tony
and I hadn't were at an IPCC meeting he
was then with the NASA at that point and
we had we were working the impacts I was
actually part of the Japanese team but
but you know American and I looked into
the Deputy Prime Minister's of the
Soviet of the bookmark arion Oh
socialist soviet federative republic the
curb Dina in Bulgarian public was
sitting next to me and he saw he saw his
American so he challenged me to a vodka
coughing contest and the and you know it
was after the first three classes I
could have been a goner but Tony Tony
saw my plight so tiny realized that
mineral Volga looks our muddle water it
looks just like vodka so he started
refilling he started refilling my glass
with with metal water and you know and
the and the Deputy Prime Minister was
ended up under the table and and about
15 months later the Soviet Union
collapsed so so we blamed a little bit
of credit for that well this'll Tony
will be with us and he's an expert on
mitigation adaptation biodiversity at
moving from the University of Maryland
global change center to a new position
on the faculty at Boston University so
please join us next week as well thank
you
thank you